con fronteras cerradas y restricciones a
los desplazamientos alrededor del mundo
la pandemia tuvo un gran impacto en las
migraciones internacionales dado que la
mayoría de países restringieron las
libertades de movilidad para frenar la
expansión del coronavirus el informe
anual de la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico la
ocde
afirma que la migración permanente hacia
países ricos cayó más de un 30 por
ciento hasta los 37 millones el nivel
más bajo desde 2003
los flujos migratorios fueron
fuertemente afectados por la pandemia de
hecho si excluimos las transiciones de
migrantes permanentes del país de
destino a otro la caída del 40% sainz es
el factor del philips el número de
nuevas solicitudes de asilo en países de
la ocde disminuyeron un 31 por ciento en
2020 la mayoría de solicitudes de asilo
provienen de ciudadanos originarios de
venezuela afganistán y siria algunos
cambios en la política migratoria de
ciertos estados de la ocde en 2020
simplificaron los procesos para las
personas desplazadas por ejemplo
facilitar la entrada de trabajadores
esenciales en los de la salud y la
agricultura y permitir a los estudiantes
internacionales aplazar sus estudios o
seguirlos online al mismo tiempo la
pandemia también revirtió algunos
avances en materia de integración
dobló sus touring en la pérdida de
empleados en 2020 afectó
desproporcionadamente las personas
migrantes a pesar de los planes para
mantener trabajos ejecutados en varios
países de la ocde se abrió una brecha un
2% entre las tasas de desempleo de los
nacidos en el extranjero respecto a la
de los locales la ocde también examinó
el impacto de la migración en las
economías nacionales concluyendo que los
inmigrantes pagan más impuestos que los
beneficios que reciben a cambio